voici la deuxième partie de notre
émission sur la faculté de médecine de
besançon
aujourd'hui nous verrons le secteur de
la recherche et l'avenir du centre
hospitalier universitaire mais avant que
nous retrouvions le doyen manière le
professeur grands motets définit ce
qu'est le centre de génétique de
besançon un centre unique en son genre
l'implantation du centre de génétique à
pezens on était là des soucis constant
des responsables de la faculté et ceci
pour deux raisons
ces installations font partie de
l'équipement d'un centre hospitalier
universitaire tels que l'autre la
génétique médicale qu'est ce que c'est
bien c'est évidemment une forme de la
médecine très scientifique mais c'est
également une forme de médecine qui rend
des services éminents la population
d'une région par le dépistage par la
prévention de certaines maladies comme
des arriération mentale comme des
malformations congénitales dans
certaines sont curables lorsqu elles
sont dépistées suffisamment tôt la
génétique médicale fait partie de
l'équipement sanitaire une région qui
améliorent la santé générale de la
population
la recherche est un point très important
puisque c'est un des axes d'expansion
sur lesquels nous envisageons de diriger
la faculté pour l'avenir est déjà
actuellement le développement de
recherches sont sont très élaborés
puisque si vous voulez nous pouvons
considérer que nous avons deux grands
groupes de recherche nous avons d'une
part les à la recherche en médecine dont
par la recherche en pharmacie la
recherche en médecine est
essentiellement marquée par des
regroupements et en particulier par
l'existence d'une part du centre de
de génétique qui est lié au laboratoire
de recherche de cytogénétique lui-même
partie prenante du laboratoire
d'histologie d'embryologie et d'autre
part le groupe de recherche concertée
qui est un regroupement des divers
laboratoires et l'univers service de
recherche avec mise en commun du des
personnes et du matériel permettant des
recherches approfondies sur certains
thèmes très poussées et très cher dans
ce groupe de recherche du concept et on
rencontre les disciplines les plus
importantes telles que l'anatomie tels
que l'anatomie pathologique quelques
l'hématologie la bactériologie la
physiologie la biochimie la
pharmacologie la médecine expérimentale
qui sont toutes des disciplines
regroupées dans le sens du développement
des connaissances des maladies et des
connaissances thérapeutique de siemens
profession verrons comment fonctionne ce
groupe de recherche concertée et bien ce
groupe de recherche concertée rassemble
dans un groupement qui s'est constitué
sur des affinités d'apport amical plus
que sur des contraintes administratives
rassemble essentiellement les
biologistes et également les cliniciens
qui sont intéressés par la promotion de
la biologie et de la recherche à la
faculté de médecine de besançon
nous mettons en commun tout le matériel
que nous possédons dans différents
laboratoires particulièrement le
matériel lourd et nous mettons en commun
également les techniques que dont nous
disposons pour utiliser ce matériel est
également nos connaissances qui sont
très diverses étant donné les
spécialisations de chacun et nous avons
un programme de recherche qui est très
vaste
il est indiqué sur le tableau un certain
nombre de thèmes sur lequel travaille
un nombre important d'entre nous se
tenait évidemment pas limitative parce
que certains d'entre nous sont très
spécialisés et trouveront une place un
peu difficile
difficilement dans cette énumération
mais c'est le propre des jeunes faculté
je parle ici quelques années la marque
propre de besançon sur ce groupe sera
plus l'aide d'une planète maintenant
mais nous sommes un peu des pieds levés
d'autre part nous avons le groupe un
groupe important de recherche en
pharmacie tels que les recherches qui
s'effectue en pharmacie chimiques et les
recherches qui s'effectue en
chimiothérapie anticancéreuse
nous venons de citer les données de la
recherche dans notre pays quitte et bien
je pense que c'est sur ces données de la
recherche et sur son implantation que
doit d'être considérés l'avenir de
l'expansion de notre faculté dans le
cadre non seulement de la région mais
dans le cadre extra régional car il est
bien entendu que d'autres facultés doit
dépasser le rayonnement régional elle
doit d'avoir un rayonnement national et
international et sa situation
géographique
je crois le peut le permettre à
condition que le développement
scientifique soit correspondants et dans
ce développement scientifique nous avons
déjà actuellement grâce aux
implantations actuelles réalisé
l'isolément d'une unité d'enseignement
et de recherche à dominante recherche et
je pense que dans l'avenir nous avons
déjà des prévisions en ce qui concerne
l'implantation d'autres unités de
recherche dans l'avenir nous espérons
fondons beaucoup d'espoir sur le nouveau
chu de châteaufarine et nous pensons que
s'il la faculté doit continuer à
s'agrandir
du point de vue nombre d'étudiants à ce
moment là deux unités pourraient être
créés et nous pourrions en ce moment là
travailler dans les mêmes conditions
avec le directeur général du centre
hospitalier régional monsieur ce lien
nous allons voir comment se présente cet
ensemble de châteaufarine dont les
travaux doivent commencer l'année
prochaine et bien l'avenir le voici sur
plan pour l'instant c'est le futur
ensemble château paris situé sur la
route de dole à 5 km de besançon et sur
un terrain d'environ 28 hectares
partagée pour moitié entre la faculté et
le chr avec son éditeur de châteaufarine
je vais donner la parole à monsieur
blanc mot collaborateur qui va vous
donner quelques explications sur la
conception du bloc de châteaufarine
d'ensemble de châteaufarine comprendra
treize centrales de vie avec 15 niveaux
d'hospitalisation de 90 du siècle
l'arrivée des urgences se fera par le
niveau rez de chaussée bas en contact
direct avec les blocs opératoires et
tous les radios exploration etc
ils sont en contact direct aussi avec le
sous sol où se fera tout les
stérilisations tous les autres deuxièmes
et troisièmes sous sol sera réservé au
service des quotas et autres services
techniques et la partie universitaire du
siège de paris viendra en extension de
ce que vous avez vu de ce qui existe
actuellement à saint jacques et à
l'arsenal elle sera constituée d'une
série de bâtiments une série de
bâtiments dont une partie seront
essentiellement constitué de
laboratoires de recherche qui seront
imbriquée avec les laboratoires du
centre hospitalier une perte d'une autre
partie faite de bâtiments purement
d'enseignement et l'ensemble de ses
bâtiments de ces unités seront liés à
des terrains de sport à des bâtiments de
sol des salles de sport et en extension
sur l'arc de cercle à des logements
d'étudiants et des installations pour
les étudiants de façon à ce que
l'ensemble de leurs activités ne se
disperse pas et reste dans le cadre de
ce campus je pense que les francs
comtois sont
tout à fait apte à assumer une telle
expansion de leur faculté de médecine
parce que ils ont un caractère très
particulier et des qualités très
particulière et il y à un haut fond de
chacun un peu ses qualités que l'on
retrouvait chez pasteur et qu'elle est
épuisée dans le terroir qui permettent
le laisse la possibilité le
développement d'un génie scientifique
parce que les francs comtois sont des
gens laborieux tenace dans le coeur et
chaud et sensible est dans la logique
est subtile associé à une imagination
ardente